Okay--so, cool. Let's try this out in practice.
So here we are in our Editor--here's our form HTML.
We're going to have to edit this to make it a little bit more complex.
And I want to put in a few new lines as well
to make it a little bit easier to read.
So I'm done editing the HTML.
I've actually only made a fairly small change
but I put some new lines in here so we can read it.
So now we've got ,
the string, Month--which is what it said before,
and our field--and I've added
this new value parameter for (month),
and I've added another one for (day), and another one for (year).
And we're going to pass these values in
to our function below
so that our form renders extra values.
Okay. So let's edit the function below
and put this whole thing together.
We're going to edit, now, our write_form function.
We're already passing in error--let's add in the other parameters.
So I'm adding the extra parameters, and they're all going to
have defaults to (blank) month, day, and year--
nothing crazy about that.
and let's also edit our Dictionary that we pass into the form
to use these variables.
We've updated the dictionary; now we're passing these variables
into this dictionary, which gets passed into our form string.
And so, now, whenever we write the form,
our form function--our write_form function--
can take extra variables to populate the form.
Let's make sure everything still works the way it did before--
before we go ahead and call this function.
Here we are in our browser; let's type in: some junk,
submit our form, and see if everything works.
Okay. We didn't get an exception; nothing broke--
so we're in good shape.
Let's go ahead and get these fields populated.
Here's our new write_form function, here's our POST function.
Here we've got our three variables that represent
what the user entered--we're getting them from the request here.
Let's edit our POST function
to use these new variables.
Now we're going to have to restructure this a little bit because
right now we're calling valid_month on the request parameters.
And if one of these parameters is invalid,
we're just going to get False back,
and that's not what we want--so we need to change just a little bit.
So let's restructure this.
So I got rid of our calls to valid_month, day and year--
and user_month just equals
what the user actually entered in for month, day, and year.
And then I'm going to use different variables
to test their validity, and I'll add those now.
Okay--so I separated the calling of valid_month, day, and year
from fetching the parameter out of the request.
And this is so we can have both variables
that represent whether the values are valid or not,
and also variables that represent what the user actually entered--
because we may have to reuse those.
Okay--so let's change our validity check now
to use the proper variables.
Okay. I've changed our validity check here
to make sure we're using month, day, and year now--
those variables instead of user_month, day, and year.
And now let's change our call to write_form.
And now I'm passing in these strings
that the user originally entered
into our form so that when we have an error
we'll render the form with whatever the user typed in.
Let's give this a shot in production.
So we've got our form; let's type in: some junk.
When we submit our form now what we should see
is an error message and our form field should still have our values in it.
There we go.
It doesn't even look like our form was rerendered
because all that appeared was our error message.
That's pretty neat, huh?
And let's make sure that submitting the correct answer still works.
Okay--so we're going to enter in real data.
This is going to go through our validators,
and let's submit this form: success!
So it rejected our bad form and it accepted our good form.
That's pretty cool.
So I've entered in a normal dau and a normal year
but in a month, I've entered in a quote
and some more text.
What's going to happen when I click the Submit button?
Are we going to see an error message and our inputs will be on our form
--you know--our normal error behavior?
We'll see an error message, but quote messes up our HTML?
Will we cause on error on the Server side?
Or will the page just render: blank?